[Music]
surpassing the level of services and
events in locations it was a double to
live it is bicultural to get on
present google maps of / race world it is
achieved with an aura of jude on google maps
because it was news that it is here we are in
our  point we attracted for the first
time a location service google maps event
for latin america with doctors and
we are in mexico city
and df doing it there and it is a
real pleasure to have this event for example
we invite all the most
important executives  from mexico start-up companies
that want to integrate their businesses through
map technology and today
we had the great opportunity not only to
have the academic board but
to broadcast the event live to more than
five countries we were live with
argentina colombia mexico and chile and
although we are  more than 10,000 people
and companies can use this
technology that is already within reach and that
many companies are already using to
enhance  your business
and
[Music]
google we feel that it is like the best
platform there is so that a user
who does not know about maps can use
the frames to better locate your
store to strategically locate it
tends to see where it makes sense to have
a store that bank is  more profitable your
products can reach your
customers easier so that your customers can
get to your stores easier and
vehicle tracking in the case you
are in the logistics area and
optimize
routes can actually be used in several
areas of  every business
we want Latin America and Mexico
there is a spectacular market with
interesting opportunities there is a lot of
innovation many startups
emerging and we would like to work and be
partners with these companies to continue
helping them in their growth includes
technological transformation connection with
his death in Mexico in business game
bilderberg and google map in technology in
my show profile